So, ist aber ganz knapp hier, kurz vor Bedgetime, mal gucken ob das überhaupt funktioniert,
ob Twitch noch realisiert, dass da Stream on ist.
Ackermans, genau.
Das ist ja richtig, ja.
Sag mal, weiß man eigentlich schon wann die neuen iPhones rauskommen dieses Jahr?
Wahrscheinlich wieder September oder Oktober oder so, ne?
Wann ist immer dieses Ding, ich blicke da bei Apple nicht mehr durch, wie das jetzt heißt,
Herbst, ja sowas, ne WWDC war doch schon, oder?
WWDC war doch schon, ich blicke da nicht mehr durch bei Apple, das ist laufend, kein Schimmer.
Swerd 7, vielleicht heißt es auch Swerd, Dankeschön für 3 Monate, Massive Prime Subscription.
Ich muss auch ins Bett gehen in einer Stunde, Stunde ist Wupp Bettge angesagt.
Letztes Jahr war Apple sehr erfolgreich, habe ich gelesen vorhin, also Apple hat glaube
ich mit das Erfolg, weiß ich nicht ob es das erfolgreichste Jahr war letztes Jahr, aber
es hat sich mega gut verkauft alles.
Es haben sich ja wohl jetzt zum ersten Mal so richtig Leute Apple Watch Dinger gekauft
letztes Jahr, wo ich auch nicht so genau verstehe, na gut, jeder wie er will, aber ich glaube
die ist jetzt auch billiger.
Na Keynote, mit Keynote ist ja eigentlich immer nur die Eröffnungspräsentation gemeint.
Hör ich mich anders an, echt, ich habe heute viel gemietet, Sekunde, höre ich mich anders
an, das muss ich mal testen, Test Test, höre ich mich anders an, Test Test, höre ich mich
anders an, ich höre mich nach Hetzand Mikro an und nicht nach, ähm, nicht nach Plojety
Mikro, mit dem Plojety höre ich mich schon besser an, aber das Hetzand Mikro ist halt
auf Dauer angenehmer, so zeige ich mal her, mit dem Plojety höre ich mich schon besser
an, aber das Hetzand Mikro hört sich doch eigentlich an wie immer oder, ist es anders
an heute, ich merke da keinen Unterschied, ah wartet mal, wobei das habe ich doch eben
schon geguckt, ne, ist auch richtig, keine Ahnung, wieso kurz, ja weil 22 Uhr Betke
ist, wie immer, Betketime, wisst ihr was ich heute gemacht habe, ne, ne, ne, ne, damit
fangen wir nicht an, guck mal, ich zeige euch mal was ich heute gemacht habe, ich habe heute
meine Tür Gegensprechanlage wieder aufgebaut, äh, äh, ausgebaut, ich gebe zu, ich gebe
zu, Optik, Optik ist noch verbesserungswürdig, ja, also das sieht vielleicht alles ein bisschen
behelfsmäßig aus, aber irgendwie muss ich das ja stapeln, aber es funktioniert, so,
ähm, also hier, die Kisten sind nur, weil die Kabel nicht lang genug sind, so, ich hätte
natürlich auch in den Keller gehen können, aber ich hatte keinen Bock im Keller rum
zu wursten, also, mir geht es nicht nur darum, dass ich höre, äh, mir geht es nicht nur
darum, dass ich mitbekomme, wenn jemand klingelt an der Tür, das ist gar nicht der Punkt, ich
möchte mit den Leuten reden können an der Tür, sowohl über die Gegensprechdinger an
der Wand, oben oder unten, allerdings auch über meine Decktelefone und auch über das
Handy, so, das heißt, ich habe jetzt am Start, habe ich heute zusammengestöpselt, habe ich
mir auf Ebay gekauft, so einen offiziellen Adapter für meine Tür Gegensprechanlage,
quasi dieses interne Ding auf Analogtelefon, das Ding braucht 14, frag mich nicht was mit
diesem Hersteller los ist, dieses Ding braucht 14,6 Volt AC, ich weiß nicht warum 14,6 Volt,
keine Ahnung, zumindest geht es auch mit einem 12 Volt, so, das hier ist, das hier ist, äh,
das Netzteil, und das hier ist ein analoges Telefonsignal auf Deckt-Umwandler, meine Güte,
ey, was, was ein Act, so, dann musste man, dann musste man das Ding über irgendeine
eingebaute Tastatur programmieren, auch Payne's Champ, dann musste ich mir noch eine extra
Decknummer kaufen, äh, eine extra, eine extra SIP-Nummer kaufen, die ich nur dafür verwenden
kann, jetzt funktioniert es ganz, ganz grausam, Leute, ich sage es euch ganz grausam, ich
gebe zu, das sieht jetzt nicht nach Big Brain Smart Klingel aus, ist aber nice, ich bekomme
jetzt auf dem Handy mit, wenn es klingelt, ähm, und ich kann mit den Leuten reden, was
die wahrscheinlich verwirren wird, wenn das nächste Mal der Amazon Mann oder wer auch
immer bei mir klingelt, dann sage ich ja hallo, dann sagt er ja hier ist Amazon, dann sage
ich ja ich bin grad nicht da, schmeiß es übers Tor, dann sage ich aber ich rede doch
grad mit dir, wie kann das sein, dass du nicht da bist, das versteht er, aber das ist glaube
ich zu viel, gibt es kein gescheites Teil auf IP, was, was verstehst du an einem gescheiten
Teil auf IP, sieht aus wie von Electro, ja nur, dass ich mich dabei nicht fünfmal geschockt
hab, das ist ja im Prinzip auf IP, überlegt euch mal, an wie vielen Stellen da, äh, nee,
vor allem was, vor allem was soll IP sein, ZIP, oder was, machst du das auf Spaß oder
beides, ähm, was wollte ich jetzt sagen, Chat, was hab ich hier mal angefangen, ich
wollte irgendwas, ich wollte irgendwas erzählen, das, achso genau, also, wisst ihr was da
alles schief gehen kann, App, nee, App willst du nicht, App willst du nicht, App ist meistens
Hersteller Cloud, die haben was, die haben was, 350 Euro, erstmal richtig, richtig big
brain, teures Geld, 350 Euro, dann nur über ihre Server und nur mit offizieller App, nee,
nee, nee, nee, über ZIP gehts jetzt ja am Ende, aber wisst ihr was da alles schief
gehen kann, also, es klingelt jemand an meiner Hoftür, dann klingelt das Telefon, okay,
daraufhin erkennt dieses Ding, es hat jemand geklingelt, wenn jemand klingelt, dann geht
das hier über das analoge Kabel, per normalem analogen Telefonanruf, an dieses analoge,
auf Deckt Übersetzungsding, so, dann schickt das Deckt Teil an die Fritzbox, weil die Fritzbox
ist Basisstation, die Fritzbox, die macht daraus ZIP und schickt es zu meinem VoIP-Anbieter,
der VoIP-Anbieter schickt es dann, also, das ganze geht dann natürlich noch übers Mobilfunknetz
an mein Smartphone, dann gehe ich da dran und dann wieder zurück und erstaunlicherweise,
und erstaunlicherweise funktioniert das, was ist bei dir zu Hause noch nicht digital,
ich wollte jetzt was richtig Dummes sagen, z.B. mein Türschloss ist, du hast es erkannt,
das wollte ich eigentlich gerade so aus dem Bauch raus sagen, also mein Türschloss ist
noch nicht digital und das habe ich auch nicht vor, ich kenne den Anbieter vom Hörensagen,
habe ich noch keine Erfahrung mit, aber wenn man sich Bewertungen durchliest, scheinen
nicht so die Geilsteile, die Mikrowelle ist tatsächlich auch nicht digital, ich verwende
aber so gut wie keine Mikrowelle, der Toaster, na der Toaster ist so, naja, der Toaster ist
nicht digital, aber der Toaster ist immerhin an einer schaltbaren Steckdose angeschlossen,
ich bin gerade ehrlich gesagt überfragt, warum, hat jemand eine Idee, warum ein Toaster an
einer schaltbaren Steckdose angeschlossen ist, tja, ich weiß es nicht, er ist aber an
einer schaltbaren Steckdose angeschlossen, ich weiß nicht, was ich mir dabei gedacht
habe, ah doch, ich weiß wieder, was ich mir dabei gedacht habe, das ist eine Steckdose,
an dem einen ist das Radio dran unten in der Küche und an der anderen Steckdose ist der
Toaster dran, das ist so eine doppelte und ich wollte den einfach nicht lernen, den kann
ich an jede x-beliebige andere Steckdose auch stecken, oh, Dorpy wollte ich mir nicht geben,
Dorpy ist, also alles das, was ich gesehen habe, ist das eine ultrafricke Lösung mit
so vielen komplexen Unsicherheitsfaktoren, dass mal was nicht geht, das wollte ich nicht,
außerdem, außerdem hast du da andere Probleme, die ich, wo ich auch keinen Bock drauf habe,
du musst dir überlegen, wo baust du es ein, du musst ja das Ding komplett selbst basteln,
da hab ich keinen Bock drauf, ich wollte ja die Anlage weiterverwenden, die da ist,
weil die funktioniert ja an sich, an sich ganz gut, nee, Dorpy wollte ich mir nicht
geben, warum ist das übrigens von 2016, kann das sein, dass das ziemlich outdated, overrated,
rebated ist, nee, nee, nee, das war mir nix, du hast das in das Gehäuse reingefrickelt
oder, oder wie hast du das mit der Siedleranlage verbunden, das geht ja gar nicht ohne weiteres,
also zumindest nicht direkt an die Kabel dran, wenn das Siedlerzeug drauf ist, du kannst
die verbauten Kabel verwenden, ja, übrigens, wisst ihr eigentlich, dass Tür-Gegensprechanlagen-Zeug
wirklich komplett schwarze Magie ist, ich hab jetzt die letzten Tage einen Raspberry
Pi hier dran hängen gehabt, mit einem Analog zu Digitalkonverter und hab mir angeguckt,
wie sich das Ding verhält, wenn man klingelt und wenn man spricht, jetzt pass mal auf, also
das ist wirklich, das ist wirklich richtig Bigprank gemacht, also, wenn das, wenn nichts
ist, wenn nichts ist, dann sind so ungefähr 17 Volt auf der Leitung, DC, so 17 Volt hier
auf diesen zwei Adern von der Tür-Gegensprechanlage, wenn es klingelt, dann geht es kurzzeitig
auf 20 Volt oder ein bisschen über 20 Volt, damit signalisiert das quasi, es klingelt,
das ist alles richtig, eigentlich Low-Brain, aber doch gleichermaßen Big-Brain, analog,
so und wenn es dann geklingelt hat, dann geht die Spannung runter auf 14 Volt, das heißt
daran erkennt das Telefon, ok, jetzt ist gerade 30 Sekunden, innerhalb der 30 Sekunden Zeit,
wo jemand geklingelt hat und das geht danach wieder hoch auf 17 bis 18 Volt, wenn 30 Sekunden
rum sind, man nicht mehr sprechen kann, also, ja und wer sich jetzt fragt, wie kommt denn
die Sprache über diese zwei Kabel, das wird da aufmoduliert, auf diese dann 14 Volt,
das ist der Wahnsinn, also das ist Low-Brain und Big-Brain in einem, aber es ist so gemacht,
dass du eigentlich außer den offiziellen Herstellergeräten oder was, was wirklich genau darauf ausgelegt
ist, du nicht verwenden kannst, das ist wirklich astral, nee, keine falsene Mode, gut, also
Videokamera habe ich anders gemacht, Video habe ich hier außen an der Wand jetzt einfach
eine Kamera hängen, hat sich bis jetzt noch keiner beschwert, gut, das ist, ich gebe zu,
das ist nicht die auffälligste Kamera, aber wenn man in den Fensterrahmen guckt, dann
erkennt man die Schrottung, juckt kein, ja, also, es ist noch keiner beschwert, kann ich
die Tür, kann ich die Tür filmen, benutzt du Tablets oder Smartphones, wo du das drauf
anzeigst, wenn ja, welche App nimmst du, um das zu verbinden, ja, sowas könnte man
tatsächlich machen, das ist eine richtig gute Idee, das habe ich für meinen Heizlüfter
im Bad gemacht, ich habe gesagt, wenn der Heizlüfter länger läuft, glaub, als eine
halbe Stunde nach dem Einschalten, dann soll er sich automatisch abstalten, irgendwie sowas
habe ich da eingebaut, achso, HomeKit, ne, da habe ich bisher großen Punkt umgemacht,
so viel verbraucht der Kram doch gar nicht, ich habe jetzt mal ein ganzes Rack ausgemistet,
habe ich euch ja gezeigt in dem einen Video, ein Tipp, wenn der Shelly 1 nicht in die Schalterdose
passt, boah, keine Ahnung, es gibt mittlerweile 1-2 Alternativen, habe ich aber gerade nicht
im Kopf, weiß ich aber nicht, ob die kleiner sind, es gibt 2-3 Alternativen zum Shelly,
nicht Sonoff, Sonoff sind die ollen Dinger, ich habe letztens, ich habe letztens ein Video
gesehen, wo einer, eine Shelly Alternative gezeigt hat, das hieß irgendwie, irgendwie,
ich weiß es nicht mehr, da habe ich ein Video zugesehen und die könnten tatsächlich ein
Ticken kleiner sein, ne, aber ansonsten, ansonsten könnte man sich noch überlegen, je nachdem,
was du machen willst, ob es nicht eine Steckdose tut, die du schalten kannst, aber du wirst
ja schon überlegt haben, warum es ein Shelly sein soll, ne, weiß ich nicht, ne, keine Ahnung,
aber der Chat weiß, doch, doch, gleich, gleich, deswegen sage ich ja nur kurz das Stream,
ja schon ein paar Leute, der Gamescom und sogar ein paar Azubis mittlerweile, Macke brecht,
3 Monate, Dankeschön für den Zap, Huge Prime Subscriptions hier, ja, wie hast du eigentlich
deine eigenen ESP32-Geräte als Device in Home Assistant registriert, einfach als Device
beim MQTT-Payload vom Sensor hinzugefügt, ja, aber ich edit keine einzelnen Sensoren,
Home Assistant hat so einen Auto-Discovery-Protokoll über MQTT, da kannst du quasi direkt sagen,
ich bin Device XY, ich habe Sensoren ABC und dann taucht das als eigenes Device auf,
in der, glaub, MQTT-Integration, das ist besser als einzelne Sensoren, dann ist das alles
schön nach Gerät zusammengefasst, ja, ich weiß auch nicht, Betke, ich hatte noch eine
Stunde Zeit, nachdem ich heute den ganzen Tag an meiner smarten Klingel, na gut, ganzen
Tag ist übertrieben, halben Tag an meiner smarten Klingel Proof of Concept rumgebaut
habe, die nicht schön aussieht, aber funktioniert, ja, so kann es passieren, was, wenn der Shelly
nicht passt, kann man versuchen, falls du die Klemmen links und rechts hast, statt dessen
Schrauben zu nehmen, die in die Dose reingehen, hat das Problem, ah, Big Brain, ich habe
zwar keine so genaue Vorstellung, meinst du, meinst du die Schrauben, du meinst die Schrauben,
wo letztendlich der Schalter vorne dann auch dran hängt, dieser Metallrahmen vom Schalter
oder was, was soll die Klingel können, die Klingel, die kann klingeln und ist eine Gegensprechanlage
und mein Ziel war, dass ich die Gegensprechanlage und das Klingeln auf meine Decktelefone bekomme
und auf mein Smartphone, was funktioniert, was aber echt nicht so easy war, das ist aber
kein Problem, ich werde dieses ganze Konstrukt einfach, ich meine, das sind ja im Prinzip
nur drei Geräte hier, wireless per Deck zur Fritzbox, ich verfrachte dieses ganze, ganze
Gedöns einfach in den Keller und dann ist Ruhe, wie kriegst du es auf Smartphone, naja,
habe ich ja gerade schon mal erklärt, also es klingelt, wie fandest du Diablo 2 Beta,
sage ich gleich was zu, sage ich gleich was zu, also wie kriegst du es, wie kriegst du
es auf Smartphone, wie gesagt, es klingelt, dann geht das hier über die Kabel da rein,
das Teil macht dann einen analogen Telefonanruf draus, wählt meine Telefonnummer, das geht
dann über das analoge Kabel in diesen analog zu Deckt Umwandler, dann geht es per Deckt
an meine Fritzbox, von der Fritzbox geht es per ZIP zu meinem VoIP Anbieter ins Internet
und dann geht es quasi übers Internet Mobilfunk an mein Smartphone und wieder zurück und
das Erstaunliche ist daran, dass der Kram funktioniert, ja also ich muss sagen, die Diablo 2 Beta
fand ich erstaunlich gut, es gab ein bisschen Bugs, ich habe Progress verloren, weil die
Surfer gecrashed sind und sowas, aber ich fand die erstaunlich gut, also ein bisschen
wenig, viel zu wenig, viel zu kurz, scheint mir aber nach einer echt guten Umsetzung
auszusehen, unfassbarer Umweg, ja, es ist echter Wahnsinn mittlerweile, wie man von
einfachem Telefon zu einmal um die halbe Welt ins Internet muss, damit man irgendwo
rauskommt, ja, aber was willst du machen, ne?
Ich finde 40 Euro durchaus in Ordnung, wenn man sich überlegt, das ist ein Spiel, wo
du tausende Stunden reinsenken kannst.
An welchen Punkten in diesem Verbindungsprotokoll benutzter klingt Blockchain?
Da bin ich gerade noch meine AI am Trainieren, dass sie rausfindet, wo ich am besten Blockchain
einbaue.
Übrigens heute, heute auf der Arbeit, so geil, wollte, hat sich jemand gewundert, warum man
bei Serverless noch Server braucht, habe ich auch gefragt, warum man das dann Serverless
hat, wenn man noch Server, Server angeben muss, gut, Serverless heißt ja im Prinzip
eigentlich nur umschrieben, es läuft woanders, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ich war nicht auf,
ich war das letzte Mal auf der Arbeit, war ich letzte Woche Dienstag, ich habe am Donnerstag
übrigens Leute, Monka Corona, am Donnerstag ist soweit, ja, ups, ich wollte irgendwas mit
etwas angenehmerem Hintergrund machen, deck, so, Donnerstag ist es soweit, zweite 5G Antenne
aus dem anderen Arm, übrigens habt ihr schon, habt ihr schon die neuste Massive Brain Logik
gelesen, also ich weiß jetzt was es mit Corona und allem auf sich hat, ich wurde nämlich
erleuchtet in einem YouTube Comment, lest euch, lest euch das mal durch ey, also ich
weiß nicht was mit den Leuten los ist, die haben echt, die haben echt einen harten Dachschaden,
guckt euch das doch mal an, ich mein was muss, was muss mit den Leuten falsch sein, lest
euch das mal durch, mal durch, lasst euch nicht von den Medien ablenken, sondern erkennt
jetzt die einzige Wahrheit, also wer immer was von eins, egal und die ist Jesus Christus,
was sonst, der Herr ist eure einzige Rettung, die große siebenjährige Trübsalzeit hat
bereits begonnen, kehrt um und tut Buße bevor es zu spät ist, wacht auf und lasst die Welt
los, sie ist am Ende und wird gerichtet werden, Gott liebt euch und möchte euch retten, bis
hierhin ja noch relativ normal, aber ab jetzt, ab jetzt, ab jetzt wird's, wird's besser,
die Offenbarung ist das letzte Buch der Bibel und erfüllt sich jetzt, Liebesbriefe von
Jesus auf YouTube, was, was zum Teufel sind Liebesbriefe von Jesus auf YouTube, es sind
die letzten Sekunden, dann kommt die Ent, die Entrückung und danach wird die komplette Dunkelheit
in Trübsal kommen, jetzt kommt der Hammer und jetzt kommt der Hammer und jetzt kommt
der Hammer, nehmt keine Impfung an, diese verändert die DNA und sind Vorbereitung für
das Mahlzeichen des Tieres 666 oder RfID-Chip genannt, der dritte Antichrist Barack Obama
wird diesen einführen und die Menschheit versklafen, dieser Chip wird aufgezwungen werden, nehmt
ihn niemals an, denn er wird nicht vergeben werden, das ist so krass, vor allem, wisst
ihr was ich mich die ganze Zeit frage, wenn ja Barack Obama der dritte Antichrist ist,
wer war denn eigentlich Antichrist Nummer 1 und 2, checkt das irgendjemand, also wer
war denn der erste und der zweite Antichrist, wenn Barack Obama der dritte ist, das ist
Satire, ich glaube nicht, ich glaube der meint das ernst, der Papst, das ergibt überhaupt
keinen Sinn, diese Leute sind teilweise einfach so durch, die Leute sind einfach so durch,
ja das kann sein aber dann ist immer noch die Frage wer ist der zweite, Katze was machst
du an der Tür so ein Krach, warte mal, warte mal, ich muss mal bei der Katze rein, und jetzt,
jetzt willst du wieder raus, das hat sich ja gelohnt, das hat sich ja gelohnt, jetzt ist
es rein, weil die Tür zu war und jetzt flitzt sie wieder raus, so und jetzt ist sie wieder
weg, warum habe ich jetzt Unify Access Points auf einmal offen hier, ja die ist reingepflitzt,
die ist reingepflitzt, hat hier rumgeguckt, hat schon, ah nee ist doch nicht so spannend
was hier drinne los ist, hat wieder gleich rausgeflitzt, das ist Standard Katztaktik,
oh man, mein zu Starlink Satellit, also ich glaube Starlink wird ein ziemlich großer Erfolg
werden allerdings in anderen Bereichen als man sich das jetzt denkt, also ich glaube
nicht, dass Starlink das Internet für die Masse werden wird und ich glaube, dass Starlink
das Potential hat, ziemlich großen Einfluss auf die weitere, also zukünftige Weltraum
Missionen zu nehmen, wenn da was in die Hose geht, ich glaube Starlink wird sich durchsetzen
in Bereichen, wo Leute richtig viel Asche haben, sich die niedrigere Latenz zu erkaufen
die man hat, wenn man beispielsweise einmal um die Welt oder einmal halb um die Welt will,
weil Unterseekabel ist langsamer als Starlink, normalerweise ist Satelliten, sind Satelliten
schneller, normalerweise sind Satelliten langsamer, normalerweise Kabel schneller, aber bei Starlink
ist das schöne, die sind ja deutlich näher dran als normale Satelliten, das heißt für
beispielsweise irgendwelche Low Frequency Trader oder sowas, da ist Starlink was ganz
tolles und die können sich das aber auch leisten, 30 Minuten ist Bad Kick, genau, also das Starlink
irgendwie Masseninternet für die dritte Welt gibt, habe ich noch so meine Zweifel, oder
was heißt dritte Welt, wir sind ja auch dritte Welt was Internetausbau angeht.
Ja, machen sie ja, also die Verbindung über Starlink, keine Ahnung, was weiß ich, Frankfurt,
New York ist schneller als ein paar Unterseekabel, Starlink ist eigentlich noch zu nah dran,
also Starlink fällt runter mit der Zeit, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher wie groß der Unterschied
genau ist, aber wenn du High Frequency Trader bist, machen es schon 2-3 Millisekunden aus,
das ist eine gute Frage ja, 35er Ping hat man sich früher drüber gefreut, wo ist das
Problem, 35er Ping kann durch 2,4 GHz Bewegungsmelder, bestimmt, bestimmt, 2,4 GHz ist für WLAN
in der Regel immer kacke, aber nachdem so ein Bewegungsmelder ja nur meldet wenn Bewegung
da ist, oder je nachdem, also wie das funktioniert, würde ich mal sagen eher weniger, aber Mikrowellen
sind beispielsweise auch auf 2,4 GHz unterwegs, ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob ich alles vom
letzten Shopping Stream mittlerweile geordert habe, halt mal her, gut, ist ja schon längst
gelaufen, ist auch gelaufen, ist auch gelaufen, habe ich mich übrigens komplett vergriffen
mit diesem Router, ist falsch, er switch, kann ich überhaupt nicht für das verwenden
was ich vor habe, habe ich am Start jetzt, habe ich am Start jetzt, habe ich jetzt auch
am Start, ist übrigens richtig nice, ich habe jetzt dieses, diese, wie heißt das auf
Deutsch, diese beschichteten Kupferkabel mal ausprobiert, das ist richtig cool, du erzeugst
keinen Kurzschluss und kannst ratzfatz einfach eine Kupferkabel nehmen, richtig, richtig
Big Brain Time, finde ich gut, ich mein ich würde es nur für Low Voltage Kram nehmen,
aber alles andere sind eh zu dünn, aber für LEDs oder sowas ist das richtig nice, Moment,
was für ein Ding, heute Strong Zwan IPI, ja stimmt, irgendwas mit Zwan heißt ja das
Ding unter Linux, IPsec Tunnel bei AWS zu WireGuard umgebaut, fast 4ms im Schnitt, bessere,
okay dachte eigentlich immer IPsec ist ziemlich optimiert was das angeht, hier die Map der
zweiten Welt, so, na dann, deswegen ist der Link auch dritte Welt, weil das die Map der
zweiten Welt ist, ich rieche G-Bate, Zeit fürs Bett gehen, WireGuard ist nochmal ein
Tech Performante, ja kann schon sein, stimmt das, dass ein 5G Handy fast wie eine Mikrowelle
ist, nein, überhaupt gar nicht, Quatsch, warum erzählt ihr, nein, das eine hat mit
dem anderen überhaupt nichts zu tun, mal ganz davon abgesehen, dass eine Mikrowelle
ja auch nur schädlich ist, wenn du deine Hand reinlegst und was passiert, wenn du deine
Hand in die Mikrowelle reinlegst, die wird warm, gut du kannst sie nicht anmachen, weil
du die Tür nicht zu kriegst, aber die Hand wird warm, aber auch nur weil die Mikrowelle
da mit was weiß ich 800 Watt draufballert, das macht ja der 5G Sendemast nicht, ja das
kommt auf zwei Sachen an, ob das gefährlich ist, einmal die Frequenz der Strahlung und
mit wieviel Energie die gesendet wird, also mit welcher Sendeleistung, so, denn das Gute
bei 5G ist, dass die Sendemasten ja kleiner sind, also was heißt kleiner, dass die Sendemasten
ja mehr, dass du mehr Sendemasten brauchst, aber die Sendemasten an sich dann nicht so
viel Power brauchen, nee, das ist Blödsinn, also gerade eine Mikrowelle ist ja explizit
dafür gedacht auch das Essen warm zu machen, dementsprechend, ich weiß nicht, was braucht
so eine Mikrowelle, 500, 600, 700, 800 Watt, ich hab keine Ahnung an Leistung, also die
hauen da das ganz schön mit ordentlich Sendeleistung raus, so und die Sache ist ja die, wenn du
nicht ionisierende Strahlung hast, wie zum Beispiel 5G, dann reicht die Energie der
einzelnen Teilchen, Photonen nicht aus, um beispielsweise DNA Stränge in deinen Zellen
zu beschädigen, da haben die einzelnen Teilchen nicht genug Energie für, was du machen kannst
ist dann, du kannst damit was aufwärmen, wie es die Mikrowelle macht, die Mikrowelle bringt
halt Wassermoleküle im Essen zum schwingen und, weiß ich ob man das als Art Reibung bezeichnen
kann, keine Ahnung, und dadurch wird es Essen warm, so und das kannst du auch machen, also
du könntest im schlimmsten Fall mit 5G dich aufwärmen, wenn der Maske noch Sendeleistung
hat, also da würde ich mir keine Gedanken machen, und wenn es euer Lehrer erzählt,
dann würde ich ihn mal fragen, wie er zu dieser Einschätzung kommt, warum das seiner Meinung
nach so ist, ist das das Electro Boom Video, ne, guckt euch das Electro Boom Video dazu
an, ich finde der hat das beste Video dazu gemacht, gerade weil er nicht aus der wissenschaftlichen
Physiker Ecke kommt, sondern aus der Elektronik Ecke, finde ich hat er das wirklich gut erklärt,
bei Sauspark die haben schon alles bekommen, weil Sauspark wollten sie auch ihren Opa
umbringen, indem sie ihm eine Kuh auf den Kopf schmeißen, das ist jetzt auch nicht
unbedingt realitätsnah, das ist ja als Sauspark, das ergibt nicht wirklich in der realen Welt
viel Sinn, du kannst die Frage hier nochmal posten, wenn du willst, ich kann gerade den
Discord hier nicht aufmachen, doch Mikrowelle hat 2,4 Gigahertz, ich habe ja auch nicht
den Vergleich zur Mikrowelle gebracht, das war ja hier der Lehrer von Ali KZK, ich weiß
nicht wie man, oder Ali KZK, ich hab keine Ahnung, ja Mikrowelle ist ziemlich genau 2,4
Gigahertz, das heißt, wenn du dein Handy in die Mikrowelle schmeißt, hast du schlechten
W-Ladeempfang auf 2,4 Gigahertz, ja gut, aber auf was war das, altes analoge Radio ist auf
was, paar Kilohertz oder so, ich hab keine Ahnung, das ist ja noch weniger, deswegen geht
das auch so gut überall durch, weil denkt immer dran, je geringer die Wellenlänge,
also beziehungsweise, es stimmt gar nicht, je größer die Wellenlänge, umso geringer
die Frequenz und umso besser geht es durch Sachen durch in der Regel, zum Beispiel Wände
und Dinge, ja genau, das resultiert ja dann daraus, das kommt ja übrigens auch noch dabei,
also selbst wenn du mal, ihr habt euch ja zum Beispiel ein Röntgen lassen oder sowas,
also selbst wenn du mal Strahlung ausgesetzt bist, wo die Teilchen genug Energie haben,
um die DNA deiner Zellen zu beschädigen, dann muss deine Zelle auch noch genau so beschädigt
werden, dass daraus sich Krebs entwickelt, das ist auch noch mal sehr unwahrscheinlich,
also die Chancen, dass dir nichts passiert, sind deutlich höher als die Chancen, dass
dir was passiert. Röntgen ist mittlerweile wie ein Tag sonnlich, das ergibt keinen Sinn,
das passt nicht von der Frequenz her, das eine sind Röntgenstrahlen und das andere
ist ja sichtbares Licht, guck, oh big brain, big brain Wellenlänge, vergleich zu den Strahlen
ein, kannst du nicht vergleichen, guck, so, da hast du sichtbares Licht, da hast du Ultriballett,
da hast du Röntgenstrahlen, da hast du Gammastrahlen oben drüber. Aussage vom Hausarzt, dass ich
schwachsinn, du kannst nicht, das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn, dass einmal das Röntgen so viel
ist wie einmal von der Sonne, das ist komplett andere, das ist wie wenn ich sag, einmal kurz
durch den Atomreaktor spaziert ist dann wie 2H Sonne oder was, nee das ergibt eigentlich
keinen Sinn. Genau, ja das kann, das kann dir mit Mikrowellen, also alte Mikro 2,4 Gigahertz
kann dir das ohne Probleme passieren, wenn du die alte Mikrowelle anmachst gegen das
2,4 Gigahertz Mähland, ja, ja, ja, das ist gar nicht so unwahrscheinlich, also das kann
dir gut und gern passieren, also Mikrowellen waren berühmt berüchtigt dafür, dass 2,4
Gigahertz Mähland Probleme hatte. Wollte mal fragen, ob jemand eine Empfehlung hat für
Outdoor Zauntor Video klingeln. Du meinst jetzt nicht am Eingangstor, sondern im Garten
oder wie, nee das würde ich nicht machen, das sind alles immer geschlossene Systeme,
wo du dann Probleme hast da, na gut je nachdem was du machen willst, also wenn du es natürlich
jetzt sagst, du willst es mit einem Amazon Echo Dings verbinden, dann ist so ein Amazon,
also wenn du im Amazon Ökosystem drin bist und da auch nicht raus willst und auch nicht
über den Tellerrand gucken willst, dann kann man das schon machen, ja. Hat er an sowas
wie Amazon Ring gedacht und wollte dazu ein Echo Show Achtar nutzen, damit mir das App
öffnen auf dem Smartphone zu lange dauert. Das Amazon Ring, set eine Empfehlung oder
soll ich zu, also ich kann dir nur sagen, ich würde es nicht kaufen, aber belegt es
auch daran, dass ich keinen Bock habe auf das Amazon Ökosystem. Du wolltest eventuell
auch eine Überwachungskamera vor den Außeneingang anbringen und das am besten alles in einer
Softwaregruppe, ja. Äh gut, das sind ja unterschiedliche Sachen, also für eine Outdoor Kamera im
Garten, wie weit ist das weg, also hast du da WLAN Empfang? Wirst du den Walomat machen
am 2. September? Ja, kann ich machen, warum nicht? Es kann nicht was der Chainlog gegen
die FDP hat. Meine Standardantwort wäre jetzt nichts Wirksames oder sowas, das sage ich
ja immer gerne aus so doofen Fragen, aber wie gesagt, ich tendiere aktuell zur FDP,
aber das kann sich immer noch ändern. Aktuell bekleckern sich ja alle nicht so wirklich mit
Ruhm. Ja, da will ich jetzt nicht von anfangen. Wie lange bis zum Eingang ist ok. Ähm Moment,
ich sage gleich was tu, wenn ich ran gescrollt habe. Wie lange bist du ok, das kannst du
machen solange der Unify Access Point Kabel hat, ansonsten musst du Wireless Uplink machen,
was auch geht, was auch geht. Zumindest solltest du einen stellen in deinem Unify, dass du,
also falls du eine Kamera oder irgendwas kaufst, was 2,4 und 5 GHz WLAN kann, dann stell in
deinem Unify Controller ein, dass der nicht 5 GHz erzwingt, wenn das das Gerät kann,
weil 2,4 GHz ist die Reichweite einfach um einiges besser als bei 5. Ich meine, das
ist auch eine Möglichkeit zu sagen, heute ist alles kacke, deswegen mache ich mir da
keine Gedanken drüber, also wirklich die Lösung ist es nicht. Die einfachste Variante
ist einfach alles, was man nicht in die Cloud packen muss, weil man keine Anwendungszwecke
hat, da irgendwas zu sharen, einfach nicht in die Cloud packen, damit fährt man eigentlich
ganz gut. Keine Ahnung, darfst du aber wahrscheinlich nicht, Abmahnung ist raus.
Der
hat er nicht unrecht, ich will nicht davon anfangen jetzt, da hat er jetzt ja prinzipiell
erstmal gar nicht so unrecht, wir haben zu wenig freiheit sehe ich genauso, man muss
halt mit der freiheit auch was sinnvolles machen, da scheiterts, da scheiterts ja mal
einigen, aber gut, das ist halt der Vor- und Nachteil von freiheit gleichermaßen
ne, aber ich mach, wie gesagt, ich mach dann den Warnomat am 2. September
ja gut CDU wäre ich garantiert nicht wählen, da wähle ich, also bevor ich die CDU wähle,
da wähle ich lieber, gibts die Piraten eigentlich noch, die habe ich auch mal eine Zeit lang
gewählt, als die sich noch nicht selbst zerfleischt haben, ähm, dann wähle ich lieber die Tierschutzpartei
oder sowas, also wenn ich nur die Auswahl hätte, CDU oder von den großen Parteien
nur CDU wählen dürfte, dann würde ich sagen, ok scheiß drauf, gar keinen davon, dann keine
Ahnung, Tierschutzpartei oder irgendwie sonst was, aber wie gesagt, ich tendiere aktuell
zur FDP, aber kann ja jeder machen wie er will, ich bin auch niemand, der jetzt da missionieren
geht, das kann jeder für sich entscheiden, wie er lustig ist, hast du auch welche im
Bekanntenkreis, äh, lass mal überlegen, habe ich, habe ich irgendwelche Anti-Impf-Leute,
ich meine meine Familie ist ja nicht so wahnsinnig groß, kenne ich, lass mal überlegen, kenne
ich irgendwie so ein, gut ich meine klar auf YouTube und sonst wie logisch, aber das kann
man nicht wirklich kennen nennen, habe ich, kenne ich jemand der wirklich, wir haben auf
der Arbeit einen der ist da sehr skeptisch, ja doch, also auf der Arbeit haben wir zwei,
auf der Arbeit haben wir zwei, der eine ist komplett lost, wobei ich das bei ihm nicht
verstehe, äh, der hat früher selbst mal in der Wissenschaft gearbeitet, ich glaube
bei Max Planck Institut sogar, also bei dem verstehe ich es gar nicht, der ist aber komplett
lost, der ist auch in der Zeit wo Maskenpflicht auf der Arbeit war, nicht mit der Maske rumgelaufen
sondern mit so einem komischen Mundschutz, ähm, mit so, mit so einem komischen Sichtschutz
ist er, ist er rumgelaufen, weil wisst ihr mit dieser, mit diesem, mit diesem Glas vorm
Gesicht und immer wenn man eine Maske aufgezogen hat, hat er gesagt, ich verstehe dich nicht,
ich verstehe dich nicht, ich verstehe dich nicht, also der ist komplett lost, der eine
den wir da haben, äh, und der andere der ist da, ist da nur sehr skeptisch, ja, ja, also
ich bin überhaupt, ich, ich, ich bin da überhaupt nicht so, also ich bin da mal, die Leute sollen
tatsächlich machen was sie wollen, wo wir gerade wieder beim Thema Freiheit sind, ich
würde nie so weit gehen und sagen, du musst die Leute zu ihrem Glück, Glück zwingen,
ich find sinnvoll sich impfen zu lassen, keine Frage, deswegen mach ich es auch selbst, aber
ich würde nie so weit gehen zu sagen, hey, das müssen wir Leute, Leuten aufzwingen.
Also, bald man Leute zum Glück zwingen muss, stimmt irgendwas nicht, ich verstehe zwar
nicht, warum es nicht, als warum das Argument nicht reicht, man stirbt nicht dran, ich finde,
das hat mich jetzt persönlich überzeugt, ich hab gesagt, ok, wenn ich mich impfen lasse,
dann ist die Chance, dass ich daran sterbe oder Angehörige von mir sterben relativ gering,
sondern was Gutes mache ich, so reiner, reiner selbst nutzen, ja, warum das nicht als Argument
reicht, verstehe ich nicht, ich finde, ich finde der Anreiz nicht daran zu sterben ist
schon mal, bzw.
Angehörige nicht daran sterben zu lassen, finde ich jetzt schon mal nicht verkehrt,
klingt, klingt durchaus sinnig, wie ich finde, aber ich würde nie so weit gehen und sagen,
ich bin dafür Leute dazu zu zwingen, sich impfen zu lassen.
Die müssen alle selbst zu dem Schluss kommen, deswegen finde ich es auch immer ein bisschen
blöd, wenn da so Impfpflicht hier, Impfpflicht da gesprochen wird, bevor man von dem Thema,
eigentlich habe ich keinen Bock darüber jetzt anzuhaben, aber ganz kurz, bevor man von diesem
Thema Impfpflicht anfängt, muss man doch erstmal definieren, was versteht man da drunter,
heißt das, man möchte Impfpflicht generell für alle oder heißt das man möchte es nur
für bestimmte Gruppen und wie weit möchte man gehen, wenn jemand sagt, nein mache ich
nicht, obwohl er zu dieser Gruppierung gehört, die es müsste, das geht ja von nicht mehr,
so wie wir es jetzt teilweise schon andenken, dass du Sachen nicht mehr teilnehmen darfst,
betreten darfst, bis hin zu die Polizei holt dich ab und schiebt dir die Spritze in den
Arm, also da gibt es ja ein breites Spektrum von Möglichkeiten, was man machen kann, wenn
sich einer nicht daran hält, so und das würde ich die Leute gerne mal fragen, die das befürworten,
bis wohin würden sie das befürworten, das würde mich echt interessieren, also sprich,
bei solchen Diskussionen sagen die Impfpflicht für alle, sagen die Impfpflicht nur für
Teile, zum Beispiel wenn man sagen würde, hey für Mitarbeiter im Altersheim oder so
was, das sind Sachen, die könnte ich mir durchaus noch gefallen lassen, ja aber, also, sag mal
so, nur weil es irgendwas mal für was anderes gegeben hat, heißt das ja noch lange nicht,
dass man das auch prinzipiell gut finden muss und das ist ja meistens auch eingeschränkt
ja und keine Impfpflicht, so nachdem generell jeder muss jetzt instant die gesamte Bevölkerung,
das sind einfach so Fragen, die mich interessieren würden, Leute die das befürworten, die würde
ich gerne fragen, bis zu welchem Punkt, also sprich erstens, was verstehen die drunter,
quasi alle oder nur bestimmte Gruppen und bis wohin, Impfstoffspritz aus dem Heli auf
die Leute, das wäre auch eine extrem Variante davon, ja, naja, mir ist egal, ich bin im
Donnerstag, ab Donnerstag bin ich monka Corona doppelt geimpft und dann ist mir es egal,
ja wie gesagt, das ist was, das würde ich mir auch durchaus gefallen lassen, wenn man
das sinnvoll begründen kann, wie zum Beispiel bei Masern in für die Kinder und selbst da
ist, bin ich mir noch nicht hundertprozentig sicher, ob ich eine Pflicht wirklich für
sinnvoll wäre, aber da lasse ich es mir gefallen, da lasse ich es mir gefallen, das ergibt,
das ergibt schon irgendwo Sinn, ja, also würde mich nicht wundern, wenn das so ist, ja also
mir ist das in zwei Tagen auch egal, ab 1.9. gehe ich wieder auf die Arbeit, also Homeoffice
ist ein Teil deutlich erhöht, aber ein bisschen nach Frankfurt fahren muss ich dann wieder,
das mit den bezahlenden Tests, da bin ich noch ein bisschen hin und her gerissen, ob
ich das gut oder schlecht finde, ob das sinnvoll ist oder nicht, ist schwer zu sagen, ich finde
gibt es genug Punkte dafür und dagegen, kein Homeoffice mehr, doch, ich habe noch Homeoffice,
ich habe meine Arbeitszeit, wie heißt das bei uns, ich habe einen Arbeitszeit Modell
Änderungsantrag gestellt, das ist so was, das gibt es nur auf Deutsch oder, Arbeitszeit
Modell Änderungsantrag, ja ich habe gesagt, ich will wechseln von quasi kein Homeoffice,
also vier Tage oder, sagen wir mal, volle Woche, volle Woche, kein Homeoffice mit Zeiterfassung,
will ich wechseln in flexibel drei Tage die Woche mit Homeoffice und weiter Zeiterfassung.
Da ich bettge, ja, nur noch zweimal mehr, ja, wer weiß, für Leute, vielleicht ist ja wirklich
am Donnerstag RIP, ja, warum kriege ich die zweite 5G Antenne, ist vorbei, äh, wie arbeitest
du jetzt nur noch, ne, ne, ne, vier Tage, vier Tage, aber ich mache drei Tage Homeoffice,
also ich mache zwei bis drei Tage flexibel Homeoffice, ja gut, beim Wender, also es gibt
welche, die sind eh komplett lost, der vegane Koch und der Wendler sind da, sind da ganz
vorne mit dabei, also die haben alle, ja, die, die, die, die würden sich wahrscheinlich
mit Emil gut verstehen, Barack Obama, der dritte Antichrist, da wären die wahrscheinlich voll,
voll auf einer Linie, du bist auch gestorben, dachte ich mir, irgendwas stimmt mit dir nicht,
du hast ja erst seit einem Monat subscribt, kein Wunder, 5G ist in Frankfurt, hey, Mobilfunkausbau
ist eh so ein Ding, ich hab seit Jahren, wenn ich morgens mit dem Zug fahre, Meintal Ost
Mobilfunkabbruch und zwischendurch immer, man würde eigentlich vermuten, dass wenn
man von Frankfurt nach Hanau fährt, beides doch recht größere Städte, ja, dass du
dann keine Mobilfunkunterbrechung hast, aber ich weiß, als diese ganze Corona-Geschichte
angefangen hat, haben wir eine Teamrunde gemacht, da war ich gerade am Bahnhof, da hat das Chef
angerufen, hat gesagt, hier Leute, wir müssen mal kurz reden wegen Corona und Homeoffice
und sonst was und ich hatte vier, fünf Verbindungsabbrüche, hab die Hälfte nicht mitgekriegt auf dem Weg,
richtig fail.
Ah, übrigens, Smasin, du bist wieder am Start, soll ich dir mal was zeigen, ich zeig dir mal
was, du warst doch der, du warst doch der, äh, der der Voranlagen, ähm, Tür-Gegensprechanlagen-Mann,
oder?
Nicht, dass ich es durcheinander bringe, pass mal auf, guck mal, guck mal, was ich gebaut
hab heute, also es sieht wild aus, aber ich muss, ich muss das irgendwie, ich muss das
irgendwie anschließen, ohne dass ich in den Keller rennen muss, ne, also, ich hab eine
Siedler-1, äh, 1 plus N Anlage, das hier ist 1, äh, das hier ist 7 und das hier ist 1,
oder wie auch immer, äh, so, und da hab ich mir auf Ebay das gekauft, was du letztens
geschrieben hast im Stream, ein DCA 612, so, und jetzt hab ich das so eingerichtet, wenn's
klingelt, das hier ist an den, also an den Anschlüssen für 1 und 7 dran, so, wenn's
klingelt, dann ruft mich das an, auf ne extra Nummer, hier Analog, Analog-Telefonat, geht
dann hier durch, an den Deckt-Adapter, an den Deckt-Adapter, und der Deckt-Adapter geht
dann per Deckt an die Fritzbox, die Fritzbox per ZIP an meinen VoIP-Anbieter, und das
geht übers Internet-Mobilfunknetz an mein Handy, und an meine Decktelefone, das heißt,
wenn jetzt eine an meiner Klingel klingelt, dann kann ich die annehmen entweder hier oben
an dem Ding, oder per Decktelefon oder per Smartphone, also so viel Kabelsalat ist das
eigentlich gar nicht, am Ende, am Ende brauche ich drei Kabel oder so, und, und was, was,
was sagste, hast du da Latenz drin, ja, ein bisschen dauert das schon, da muss ich erstmal
Verbindungsaufformat, also es klingelt, das klingelt, und ich sag mal so, 2-3 Sekunden
später klingelt es dann auf dem Smartphone, die Decktelefone klingelt ein bisschen schneller,
was passiert wenn du es gleichzeitig abnimmst, ähm, dann hörst du dich gegenseitig, dann
hörst du dich gegenseitig, das ist ja im Prinzip unter der Haube hier alles nur eine lange
Analog-Leitung, richtig Oldschool-Shit, das mit dem Deck-Sender ist richtig Big-Plan,
ich hab's getestet mit einem direkten Kabel zur Fritzbox, geht natürlich auch, aber warum
ich das mit diesem Deck-Sender gemacht hab, ist, ich will den Kram ja in den Keller verfrachten,
Fritzbox steht im ersten, steht im ersten Stock, und so kann ich im Prinzip dieses
ganze Ding nehmen, schmeiße es in den Keller in die Ecke, schließt an und gut ist, das
einzige was dumm ist, was denkt sich der Hersteller eigentlich dabei, dass man dieses Ding mit
14,6 Volt AC betreiben muss, das hat doch kein Mensch, ich hab da jetzt ein 12 Volt
Netzteil dran, aber was ist mit denen los, das ist komplett wir, zum Glück funktioniert
das auch so, das ist kein Bus-System, das ist noch 1 plus N, aber ein Vorteil hat das
jetzt, dadurch, dass ich so lange daran rumgebaut hab, ich blicke relativ gut durch mittlerweile
bei dieser ganzen Technik, und ich weiß, es ist komplett schwarze Magie, ich weiß zum
Beispiel jetzt auch, wie die Tür-Gegensprecher-Anlage-Anrufe signalisiert, normalerweise ist es in 17 Volt
Spannung drauf, dann wenn es klingelt, sind es 20 plus, 20 bis 24 Volt, daran erkennt das
Ding, dass es klingelt, und in der Zeit, wo man den Hörer abnehmen kann, fällt die Spannung
ab auf 14 bis 15 Volt, und wenn man den Hörer abnimmt, wird das Sprech-Signal quasi aufmoduliert
auf diese zwei Leitungen, was total Low- und Big-Brain gleichzeitig ist, total abgedrehter
Shit, was die da gebaut haben, ja und zum Glück ist es noch analoggestellt und kein
Bus-System, weil bei Bus-Systemen hast du wohl das Problem, dass diese Adapter automatisch
immer die Gespräche annehmen, und du kannst diese Handgeräte nicht mehr verwenden, es
ist mir egal, es funktioniert alles, ich lasse es jetzt so und ich fasse es nie wieder an.
Warum kriegen die Leute Timeouts, wollte er einen Timeout, ah er wollte den Timeout ok,
ist 14,6 Volt AC eigentlich auch die Versorgung von dem Türöffner, ich habe keinen Türöffner,
ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das andere Zeug auch damit versorgt wird.
Das nächste Azubi-Video, also als nächstes mache ich das Stellenanzeigen-Video, dann
wollte ich mich nochmal über 500 Tage Homeoffice und jetzt wieder ersten Tage im Büro auslassen,
dann kommt wahrscheinlich ein Azubi-Video und mal gucken.
Ja, die Strecke nach Köln hat mich auch sehr überrascht, auch Frankfurt Köln hat
zwischendrin einiges an Empfangsprobleme, gerade Frankfurt Köln müsste eigentlich
eines der besten Strecken schlechthin sein, zumal ja angeblich die ganzen Internetgeschichten
unter der Bahnstrecke gehen, was auch ganz, also was ganz, ganz schlimm ist, ist Frankfurt
Dresden, da hast du gefühlt die Hälfte der Zeit keinen Empfang, IQ plus plus, Dankeschön
Leute hier für die Subs, ihr beiden, äh wie kann man jetzt mit Prime abonnieren, einfach
den Sub-Button drücken, dann müsstest du die Auswahl haben, ja Internetausbau in Deutschland
wissen wir doch mittlerweile, ist alles so ein Thema für sich, wie gesagt ein paar Sekunden
dauert das schon, ja, ich bin schon mal, ich bin gespannt, ich bin ohne Scheiß, ich bin
richtig gespannt auf den ersten Tag, wo mal Amazon klingelt und ich geh dran und bin nicht
daheim und der Amazon Mensch glaubt mir nicht, dass ich nicht daheim bin, weil ich an der
Tür Gegensprechanlage mit ihm rede, also wie gesagt, wenn man Zeitgleich abnimmt, hört
man sich glaube gegenseitig, nee das geht relativ schnell, wie gesagt 2-3 Sekunden,
dann klingelt's, Amazon klingelt bei mir ja, übrigens Amazon, das hab ich euch ja noch
gerade erzählt, Amazon hat mal Briefkasten kaputt gemacht, die haben ein richtig fettes
Paket reingestopft in meinen Briefkasten, was überhaupt nicht für Briefkasten gedacht
ist, aber es ist nicht so wild, es ist nur die Klappe und ich denke, ich krieg die Klappe
auch wieder gefixt, aber trotzdem, es muss nicht sein sowas und dann neuen Briefkasten
auf Amazon bestellen, der Witz ist ja, was willst du machen, ganz ehrlich, was willst
du machen oder wie hätte der echte Gangster gesagt früher, was willst du tun, ja, das
sind Sub-Sub-Sub-Sub-Subunternehmer Amazon Logistics, den Fahrer wahrscheinlich seh ich
den nie wieder und bei Amazon wüsste ich noch nicht mal, wo ich mich da beschweren
sollte, geschweige denn, ob die meinen Briefkasten dann fixen, ich könnte sie verklagen, was
ich aber nicht machen werde, ich werde einfach gucken, ob ich die Klappe repariert bekomme,
ja, es ist AC, warum auch immer, wahrscheinlich weil Klingel stellt und es muss AC sein.
Ich sehe, manche kennen das noch, der echte Gangster war einfach seiner Zeit voraus, ich
auch, Leute, in einer Minute Bettge-Time, hoch, gleich Bettge, mach schon mal Bettge-Musik
an, ja, Leute, gibt's sonst noch irgendwas
spannendes, Stream ja heute noch mal kurz, knapp eine Stunde gewesen, irgendwas, 10 Minuten
habe ich noch Zeit, wird's eigentlich noch mal ein Gartenstellens Video geben, ja, weiß
nicht, wozu, letztendlich wird ja alles von dem Garten schon gesehen, so spannend ist
das nicht, dass das im Algorithmus so durch die Decke gegangen ist, verstehe ich bis heute
nicht, das war irgendein Bug im YouTube Algorithmus, definitiv, anders kann ich mir das nicht erklären,
Nebian 11 ist stable draußen nice und ist schon instant veraltet,
Da hab ich gar nichts von mitbekommen Da hab ich gar nichts von mitbekommen
Wie soll denn eine KI verschlüsselte WhatsApp Nachrichten analysieren?
Also wenn das ordentliche Verschlüsselung ist, dann sollte der Inhalt als nahezu,
sagen wir mal, random erscheinen, ja? Also wenn die Nachrichten verschlüsselt sind,
sodass die KI die nicht sehen kann, stelle ich mir schwierig vor,
wie das mit personalisierter Werbung funktionieren soll.
Es sei denn, es sei denn, die haben das auf deinem Endgerät, genau, und die können es
vor dem Absenden angucken, was dann wieder die Verschlüsselung in Frage stellt,
wenn da schon der Keylogger eingebaut ist.
Meinung IP-Tables vs. NF-Tables Ich hab NF-Tables noch nicht benutzt.
Ich hab es auch nicht vor, ich mache auch einen großen Bogen um IP-Tables,
sofern ich da nicht wirklich irgendwas unbedingt machen muss, lass ich's.
Das Verschlüsselte analysieren, okay, da wird mich echt mal interessieren,
wie die das machen. Ich hab keine Ahnung, ob das der richtige Begriff ist.
Was ist NF-Tables? Ein Firewall-Tool unter Linux.
Kommandozeilen, Firewall-Tool. Also für die kernel-Funktualität,
für die Paketfilter kernel-Funktualität. Bloat braucht man nicht, genau, ist alles bloat,
alles bloated. Gut, das meiste im Internet ist symmetrisch verschlüsselt.
Auch dieser Chat von mir zu euch ist symmetrisch verschlüsselt.
Die Frage ist nur, wie der Schlüssel ausgetauscht wird.
In der Regel wird der Schlüssel asynchron ausgetauscht und dann symmetrisch verschlüsselt.
Weil symmetrische Verschlüsselung einfach schneller ist.
Wie gesagt, HTTPS ist der TLS. Soweit ich weiß, ist der Schlüsselaustausch
asynchron und der Rest ist synchron verschlüsselt. Ja, Moment, Moment, jetzt wird mal alles durcheinander
geschmissen. Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Das eine hat mit dem anderen erst mal überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Das sind zwei komplett unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe.
Four Tables sind vor ausgefüllte Tabellen von Klartext zu Hash, oder besser gesagt von
Hash zu Klartext. Sodass du relativ schnell, wenn beispielsweise
einer, keine Ahnung, MD5 verwendet und du willst das nicht selbst alles durchprobieren
und der verwendet keinen Salt, dass du relativ einfach durchgucken kannst, ok, welche Hash
und ein möglicher dazugehöriger Plain Text. So, dafür sind Rainbow Tables da.
Das hat jetzt erst mal mit analysieren von verschlüsselten Nachrichten nichts zu tun.
Alter, Chandler, was ist wieder los hier? Aber ich sehe, Leute, jetzt ist wahrlich Bedgetime.
War nur kurzer Stream heute. Nächstes Mal geht es wieder ein bisschen länger,
versprochen. Wir sehen uns. Bis denn, wo habe ich meine Musik?
Bis denn, macht's gut, see you.